شكرا ريم ونستكمل واياكم هذه التغطيه على
مدار الساعه والتي نخصصها لما يجري
بالسودان حيث انتهت الهدنه التي شهدت نوعا
من الالتزام من طرفي النزاع فيما تواصل
اطلاق النار وذوي الانفجارات عشيه عيد
الفطر وفي العاصمه الخرطوم تسرع العائلات
بالخروج الى الطرق والفرار هربا من
الغارات الجويه والرشقات الناريه والمعارك
في الشوارع والتي اودت بحياتي اكثر من 300
شخص حتى الان
وفي تصريحات للعربيه اوضح المتحدث باسم
وزاره الصحه السودانيه محمد ابراهيم ان
ثلاثين مستشفى خرج عن الخدمه في العاصمه
الخرطوم وحدها مشيرا الى ان مخزون الادويه
والدم لا يزال جيد في مستشفيات الخرطوم
في الخمسه ايام السابقه اللي هو منذ 15
وحتى فجر اليوم
1722 مصاب واتوا الى الاستشفاء في
مستشفيات الولايه البالغ عددها 133 مستشفى
453 مستشفى 81 مستشفى القطاع الخاص مجمل
الوفيات
سجلت في المستشفيات 105 وفاء 46 في الغطاء
العام
59 في القطاع الخاص
[موسيقى]
وعلى طاوله العشاء اجتمعوا ليلا وفي ساحه
القتال تواجهوا صباحا هذه تفاصيل الساعات
الاخيره قبل انزلاق السودان الى صراع دموي
وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
ضجيج اليات العسكر لم يهدا لخمسه ايام مضت
لكنه تسلل من ليله هانئه شهدت عشاء اخيرا
بين الجنانين هدوء ظاهري اخفى تحت الطاوله
مخططات جاهزه للتحشيد واطلاق الرصاصه
الاولى طرفات صراع قطع وعودا وقدمات
تنازلات بحضور وسطاء بهدف نزع فتيل
التنافس بينهما وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
وفيما كانت الالات العسكريه المتنافسه
تستعد للقتال تدفقت القوات بهدوء على
معسكرات الجيش المتنافسه في جميع انحاء
العاصمه الخرطوم بدايه الخلاف وبحسب
الصحيفه خرجت من قلق حمد المتمتل باختراق
الجيش من قبل موالينا للنظام السابق فيما
بدات المخابرات العسكريه بقياده البرهان
في اخبار المسؤولين الاجانب بان حمد حاول
سرا استيراد طائرات مسلحه من دون طيار من
تركيا لتعزيز قوته فالخلافات لوحظت حتى
بين افراد الجيش والدعم السريع الذين
تعاملك قوتين متنافستين
وليس منسجمتين ضمن نفس الدوله لكن ما ادى
الى تفاقم الخلاف اكثر محاوله الاتفاق على
دمج القوتين في جيش واحد خصوصا ان هذه
العمليه ستخرج حمدتي الخاسره الاكبر منها
الانقلاب على الاتفاقات لم يكن الاول في
تاريخ الطرفين ففي عام 2021 فاجا
الجنرالان مبعوث الامريكي جفيف حين سقطت
الحكومه المدنيه في مسار الطريق السودان
الى الديمقراطيه عقبات كثيره وامال
الوسطاء بالتوصل لاتفاق صعبه بعد ان فجر
كل من الطرفين نواياه بوجه الاخر اياد
حمود العربيه
ومن جنوب الخرطوم ينضم الينا الصحفي مقداد
حسن اهلا بك معنا مقداد
وضعنا في صوره اخر الاخبار حتى الان فيما
يحدث من حيث انت
اهلا وسهلا بمشاهدي قناه العربيه انا انقل
لكم الاحداث التي دارت والتي تتضررت منها
هذا المجمع السكني الذي انا بداخيله الان
مجمع الرواد السكني الذي هو يقع في الجزء
الغربي الجنوبي لمنطقه الخرطوم
في جنوبه مباشره يقع معسكر الشجره ميسكر
المدرعات وبشماله مباشره بشارع الغابه يقع
معسكر قوات الدعم السريع وهو ليس ببعيد من
منطقه وسط الخرطوم ومحيط القياده العامه
ومطار الخرطوم هذا المكان الذي انا فيه
الان هو مجمع سكني مدني تماما تضررت منه
اسره عبد الله ثروت تضررا كاملا فقد كل
شيء فقد والده زوجته التي التي تصارعت
الموتى بساعتين اثراء تدمر هذا المكان
الذي اقف خلفه الان كما ترون هذه الشقه
بمجمع الرواد السكني تضررت تماما كان
حادثا ماس حاول ان ينقذ اسرته وحاول بكل
ما
يملك من وسع بمساعده المواطنين هنا لكن
ساءت الاقدار ان تلتحق ان تتوفى والده
زوجته تسلم روحه الى بريئه انا الان اضعكم
في الصوره مع عبد الله ليحكي لنا
بتفاصيل اكثر عن هذا الحديث عبد الله ما
هي الاضرار التي حدثت في هذا الحديث
القسيم في يوم امس باختصار شديد والسلام
عليكم ورحمه الله صراحه
كل شيء كل شيء كل ما يعني تعني الكلمه من
المعنى
لدمار وفقدان كل شيء حتى حتى مالي ملابسي
كل شيء كل شيء في الشقه
تدمرت تماما
من بدايته
كنا نعمل
صبيحه هذا اليوم الامس
في حدود الساعه حوالي الساعه الثامنه
والنصف صباحا
كعاده يعني كموظف
يعني لي خبره في في المجال الامني
اخذت كل كل اسرتي الى الصاله الخارجيه لكي
ننام ارضا كيف تمت عمليه الانقاذ كيف تمت
عمليه الانقاذ تمت عمليه الانقاذ
عن طريق هذه البلكونه
هذا الموقع تم الانقاذ ابنتي وزوجه الحامل
الشهر السادس
عن طريق مساعده السكان
فقمت باخذ لطفلته
وناولتها الى الشباب من تحت
وزوجتي حملتها
انزلتها بيدي الا ان تم
استلامها للاسفل عن طريق مساعده الاخرين
نعم هذا باختصار شديد ما تعرض له عبد الله
في هذه المنطقه في
مجمع الرواد السكني اثر قذيفه عشوائيه
سقطت على هذا المجمع والان بعد قليل ننقل
لكم الاضرار في هذه الشقه بتفاصيل كامله
مقداد
هل مازلتم تسمعون
طلقات ناريه اشتباكات ام ان الامور هدات
كون غدا اول ايام عيد الفطر والحقيقه
المواطن الذي اجريت معه اللقاء قد يكون
مثال على عشرات وربما مئات المدنيين الان
في السودان الذين يعانون ممن فقدوا اما
احباء لهم او فقدوا حتى ممتلكاتهم
نعم انا اثناء تحركي في هذه المنطقه منطقه
جنوب الخرطوم بين الفينه والاخرى اسمع
زهات للرصاص وطلقات هنا وهناك وكذلك سكان
هذه المنطقه اكدوا لي انهم يسمعون
المروحيات التي تجوب سماء الخرطوم بين هنا
وهنا وكذلك
المضادات الطائرات التي ترد عليها بين
الفينه والاخرى نعم من بعض الافطار الى
هذه الساعه هنالك هدوء نسبي تماما والناس
تستقبل العيد كما ذكرتي لكن نسمع على محيط
القياده العامه وعلى كذلك على مناطق اخرى
ربما هي من ام درمان يعني هذه المنطقه
تتاخم الحدود الغربيه
او هي على النيل الذي يصل ام درمان مع
الخرطوم نسمع من هنالك ضربات هنا وهناك
فهذا هو مجمل الاوضاع داخل هذه المنطقه
بالنسبه نعم
في المناطق جنوب الخرطوم وكيف هي حال هناك
يعني اخبار يتم تناقلها عن وجود جثث هنا
وهناك عن وجود
كميات من الركام كبيره جدا
كيف هي الاوضاع وانت تسير في الشوارع
انا لم اشهد بعيني اي جثث ملقاه على
الشوارع لكن الاخبار تتحدث عن ان منطقه
كرري جمال
جمال ام درمان وهي تم عرض هذه الصور ومعنى
مقداد لو سمحت لكن هنا لو سمحت ممكن
الكاميرات في المدينه تتحرك معك حتى نرى
حجم الدمار الذي وقع في هذا المجمع السكني
الذي تبث الينا الان هذه الوقفه الاخباريه
منه واكمل لي الحديث ممكن تمام تمام
بالامكان
بالامكان تحرك معي وضاح لنشاهد حجم الدمار
الذي
توصلت اليه هذه المنطقه كما ترون هناك بعض
الركام الذي
يعني حدث لهذه الاسره وكذلك هي الشقه
بالطابق الاول لهذا المجمع السكني
بالامكان ان نسير هنا الى
اليمين
الامكان ان نمشي هنا بهذا الركام الذي
كما ترون هذا لو كامل المنزل الذي تحطم
تماما
بالامكان
كما ترون هذا هو جزء من الدمار الذي
مقداد هل تسمعني ام ان الخط انقطع بيني
وبينك كما ترون
مقداد لو سمحت بدي اسالك هل يعني انت انت
كان واحد من المواطنين تحدث لك قبل قليل
او من المدنيين الذين تضرروا هذا المجمع
السكني هل هي شقه واحده ام هناك عدد اخر
من السكان ممن اضطروا للمغادره ما الذي
تعرفه عنه
انا الان اربطك برايس هذا الحي هو موجود
معي الان متوكل يمكن ان تظهر في الكاميرا
في كاميرا العربيه وخلي الكاميرا تتحرك
ونضل مع الصور وانت تتحدث الينا مقداد
طبعا لانه مقداد يتحرك هنا وهناك ظروف في
الخرطوم صعبه جدا لكننا سنعود لمقداد حسن
مره اخرى مقداد انا اسمعك تفضل
الان كما ترين انا معي متوكل هو المسؤول
من هذه المنطقه او هو رئيس اتحاد هذه
المنطقه يمكن ان يصف لنا اهميه الاهميه
المدنيه لهذا الحي وان يخبرنا بحجم
الاضرار اكثر
بسم الله والحمد لله اعتقد نحن في كارثيه
بكثافه سكانيه عاليه جدا
والكارثه حصلت في شقه اخونا عبد الله ثروت
هي واحده من عدد من يعني اصيبت عدد من
الشيطان
بعدد من الطلقات لا تقل عن سبعه
زي ما قلت المجمع ضخم مجمع كبير 17 برج
الكثافه سكانيه عاليه ولكن ما حدث في شقه
اخونا عبد الله ثروت وكان فارس حقيقيه
فقدنا في ارواح
كما كما تسمعينني الان او تسمعي متوكل هو
يقول ان هذا المجمع السكني يحتوي على 17
برجا سكنيا يعني ان الكثافه السكانيه في
هذه المنطقه كثافه عاليه وهي مجمع سكني
مجهز تماما من كل الاحتياجات المدنيه تعرض
هذا المجمع الى قصف عشوائي بين قوات
المسلحه وقوات الدعم السريع ممكن ان نتحرك
بالكاميرا الى داخل هذه الشقه التي تضررت
وان نعرض جزءا من
يعني افهم تماما كل ما تحرك مقداد حسن
يمينا ينقطع الخط انا معك مقداد نريد ان
نشاهد واياك هذا الدمار الذي حصل في الشقق
ونحن نتحدث عن مجمع سكني فيه دمار حصل
لسبع او ثمان شقق حسب ما ذكر ضيفك الان
نعم هنالك ايضا سيارات تدمرت واصيبت بهذا
مقداد ارجوك ان تبقى معنا وسنتابع واياك
هذه الصور وهذه اللقطات لانها قد تعبر عن
شيء ما مما يحدث في الخرطوم حتى لو كان
قرير جدا وخلي الصوره معنا ينضم الينا
الان من الخرطوم عبر الهاتف فارس النور
مستشار الفريق محمد حمدان دقله اهلا بك
معنا سيد فارس
والحديث عن هدنه
لثلاثه ايام القادمه فتره العيد الفطر هل
هل تم الاتفاق عليها هل
تحدث الطرفين النزاع والقتال بشانها
اولا مرحبا بك
ويعني نحن في غايه للاسف انه يمر علينا
ذكرى العيد ونحن في الظروف الصعبه والتي
يمر بها كله
السودانيين
ونحن من جانبنا
نوافق على كل ما يمكن ان يخفف على
السودانيين سواء في العيد او في غير العيد
نحن مستعدين وموافقين على كل ما
يخفف الازمه الانسانيه التي وضعنا فيها
اضطرارا
كيف فسر كيف وضعتهم فيها اضطرارا
معلومه تماما انه هذه
المعركه دبرت بالليل
وتمت مهاجمه
معسكراتنا غدرا وتم مهاجمه مغاره قيادتنا
فقررنا للدفاع عن انفسنا بسبب يعني تمت
المهاجمه هذه بسبب ماذا خلاف سياسي خلاف
على السلطه من يحكم السودان هذه المعركه
يا سيدتي هي معركه ما بين
المعسكر الذي يريد التحول الديمقراطي
وينشد تحقيق اهداف ثوره ديسمبر
والمعسكر الاخر الذي يريد ان يعود بنا الى
الى معاقل الديكتاتوريه
على الارض هل
القوات الدعم السريع قادره على مواجهه
الجيش لفتره طويله
فقط يعني انا اشكر السيد رئيس مجلس
السياده هو لخص المشهد بان في مكالمته او
محادثته اليوم لاحدى القنوات ان الدعم
السريع ينتشر في كل مكان
ويحتل المرافق الحيويه هذه اجابه كافيه
جدا
تؤكد قدرتنا وتؤكد صمودنا وتاكد اننا في
موقع متقدم رئيس مجلس السياده ايضا قال
بان الحديث السياسي مع معكم مع هذا الطرف
اصبح خلفنا لن يكون هناك عوده الى طاوله
حديث السياسي كيف ستنتهي هذه الازمه او
هذه المعركه برايك
نحن
هدفنا ان نصل الى التحول السلمي والى
التحول الديمغرافي اذا كان
عبر المعركه فهذه معركه كتبت علينا ولابد
ان نمضي الى نهايتها واذا كان من حوار
بشرط ان الاساسي ان نفضي هذا الحوار الى
حكومه مدنيه تتكلم
السلطه
وتدير الفتره الانتقاليه وصولا الى
الانتخابات التي اختار عبرها الشعب
السوداني من يمثلها توصفون الان بانكم
ميليشيا خارجه عن القانون
ومساله تصفيه الميليشيات او نزع سلاح
المليشيات وعدم الحديث
معها مساله عامه يعني على المستوى الدولي
الان اصبحتم ميليشيات لم تعودوا جزءا من
السلطه العسكريه في الدوله ولم يعد حمدتي
نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده
صرت طرف
طرف عدو عدو لدود كيف سيكون هناك عوده
نحن حكومه انشئنا ونحن قوات انشئت بقانون
والان ما يفعله البرهان
قراراته غير شرعيه
ونعلم تماما اننا
قادرين على انجاز اهداف ثوره ديسمبر
والوصول الى جيش قومي موحد نحن وافقنا على
هذا المبدا
موافقون على
ان تتوم مدنيه
صوت اشتباكات نسمعه الان وانت تتحدث معنا
صوت اطلاق نار هل ما زالت المعركه حاميه
الوطيس قرب القياده العامه ما الهدف لماذا
قرب القياده العامه هل تريدون السيطره على
القياده العامه
نحن الان نسيطر فعليا وهذا باحتراف السيد
رئيس مجلس السياده هو احترم بذلك
وبعض المناوشات التي تحدث من هنا وهنا هي
تحدث
وايضا اريد ان اقول ان الشرفاء في القوات
المسلحه هم يعني اعتقد ان هنالك غله
اختطفت قرار الجيش
وادخلت الجميع سياتون هذه الحرب لكننا نحن
نعرف ان
هنالك الكثير من ابناء القوات المسلحه هم
اخواننا وهم شرفاء وهم الان بداوا ينتبهوا
للفخ الذي تم اصطيادنا له جميعا كنتم
وصلتم يعني
لاتفاق اطاري
الانتقال للسودان لمرحله اخرى مرحله مدنيه
مرحله مختلفه عما مر به طول السنوات
الماضيه ما الذي قلب الطاوله لماذا بين
ليله وضحاها استيقظنا على هذه الحرب في
السودان
[موسيقى]
الى
الاتحاد
وتكوين اكبر جبهه مدنيه لمواجهه هذا الخطر
لمخاطبه المجتمع الدولي بضروره الانتقال
الى التحول الديموطي هل استشيرت القوى
المدنيه التي تخاطبونها الان وتدعونها
الان سواء انتم او الفريق الاخر هل
استشيرت فيما يحدث الان في السودان
المدنيين عم بدفعوا الثمن لا مالا كهرباء
لا مستشفيات في قطع طرق في عدم لا يوجد
ممرات امنه الوضع في السودان لا ينقصه
يعني سودان من افقر الدول العالميه في
الاصل
السودان ليس من ابغر الدول السودان
ونحن اصغر شعبي في اغمى ارض ولكن لان
الكثير من الذين من الديكتاتوريه والذين
يريدون ان يتفردوا بحكم الفرد هم الذين
عطلوا مقدرات لسنوات طويله ويريدون ان
يستمروا في هذا لهذا لم يستشار احد كلنا
غدرنا لهذه المعركه الاخيره غدرنا ونحن في
محل الدفاع عن النفس ونحن نقول الان الان
نحن
هذه المعركه سلما او حربا لابد ان تنتهي
بحكومه مدنيه
تسلم فيها السلطه لابناء السودان المدنيين
الذين يديرونها في فتره الانت
قاليه موقف
ها وانت بتعرف سيد فارس النور بانه هذه
المعركه هي يعني صراع بين راسين كبيرين
يعني حماتي والبرهان الحقيقه في مثل هذا
النوع من المعارك لا يمكن لطرف ان يتنازل
للطرف الطرف الاخر هل الضغط باتجاه حكومه
مدنيه سواء داخلي او خارجي يمكن ان يعتبر
نصر لكم او يمكن ان ننهي هذه المعركه
نحن بالنسبه لنا اذا كانت ثمن هو
الديمقراطيه فنحن موافقون سوف ننهي هذه
المعركه فورا اذا كان الثمن هو
الديمقراطيه ولكن لن نقبل انه الشعب
السوداني الذي مر بكل الالام من ثوره
ديسمبر وقتل فيها واستشهد فيها الجميع الى
الفتره الانتقاليه التي مرت بكثير من
الاحن والمحن لن نقبل انه الان بعد هذه
المعركه الداميه في وسط الخرطوم التي تضرر
منها الجميع لن نقبل انه يكون الثمن اي اي
تسويه لا تاتي بحكومه ديمقراطيه لا تاتي
بحكومه نوصل للحديث عن التسويه يجب ان
يكون هناك جلوس على طاوله من اجل العوده
مره اخرى للمفاوضات رئيس مجلس السياده
يقول على قواتكم ان تعود الى مواقعها قبل
ديسمبر
اللي كانت فيها قبل ديسمبر وليس الان حتى
يعني يفكر بالحديث معكم كيف يمكن الرد على
ذلك
وسوف يفكر
بالامس بالاداء افتكر يعني كلام الذي
يردده هذا كلام اذا اذا تابعوه اي شخص
تجده كلام مهزوم وكلام شخصي مهزوم لانه
انت
طرف
الاخر لا يمكن ان تقول ان الاخرين ان
الدعايه لتحتك تتكلم عن هزيمتنا
وانتشار لا يعني النصر يعني
هناك فرق يعني الانتشار قد يجعل هذه
المعركه تستمر
[موسيقى]
هل هي معركه في السوشيال ميديا ام هي يعني
اصبح يتساءلون جميع الان يتساءل لماذا حتى
اعدائنا الان يتساءلون لماذا تدار هذه
المعركه
بها الان تم شحن وتم تاجيل عواطف الناس
لاشياء غير حقيقيه على العموم نحن
افراد القوات المسلحه هم اخواننا واي دم
الحرب الكل فيها خسران نحن نريد ان تكون
هذه اذا هي اصلا كتبت لانها معركه فلتكون
المعركه الاخيره نحو الديمقراطيه هذا هو
الثمن الذي ننشده ولا ننسى اننا نتحدث عن
القوات المسلحه لدوله تحارب فصيل منشق
خارج متمرد اي شيء ممكن تسميته حسب الوصف
الذي يتم تتم يعني يتم اطلاقه على ما يحصل
الان في السودان شكرا جزيلا لك سيد فارس
النور مستشار الفريق محمد حمدان شكرا
جزيلا لك
هذا هو اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه عن
ارسالها قوات الى افريقيا لاجلاء سفارتها
او العاملين بالسفاره بالخرطوم اذا اقتضت
الحاجه واضاف الفانتاجون ان القياده
الامريكيه في افريقيا تراقب الوضع في
السودان عن كثب وتقوم بالتخطيط الحكيم
لمختلف الحالات الطارئه
يبحث رئيس مفوضيه الاتحاد الافريقي موسى
فكي الوضع في السودان مع امين عام الامم
المتحده انطونيو غوتيريش والامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه احمد ابو الغيط
بالاضافه لدول عربيه واعضاء بمجلس الامن
الدولي والاتحاد الاوروبي واضاف في كان
المشاركين دعوا لوقت فوري لاطلاق النار
بالسودان في عيد الفطر لتلبيه الاحتياجات
العاجله للسكان المحاصرين
ينضم الينا الان من واشنطن حسين الطوط
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك معنا حسين ودعني
ابدا معك بهذا الحديث عن القواعد العسكريه
الموجوده في جيبوتي التي هي على استعداد
لنقل العاملين او يعني الصين بالسفاره
الامريكيه في الخرطوم
تحيه لك منتهى بالفعل الارجح تنطلق القوات
الامريكيه ان دعت الحاجه من جيبوتي الى
السودان حسب ما اعلن ما زال يراقب الاوضاع
في السودان لاتخاذ القرار ولي ايضا لوضع
خطط طوارئ اذا اقتضت الحاجه حتى الان ليس
هناك قرار رسمي نهائي بعد
المسؤولون الامريكيون يتواصلون مع طرفي
النزاعلي حثوهم على وقف اطلاق النار
والالتزام بالهدنه ايضا مساعده الانسانيه
ولكن فيما يخص عمليات اخلاء الرعايه
الامريكيين هناك طبعا عوائق عده حتى الان
موجوده حسب مصادر تحدثنا اليها منها
استمرار القتاله في الخرطوم وفي مناطق عده
من السودان ما يعيق
وصول هذه القوات لمن اجل عمليات الاخلاء
ولكن كما فهمنا هناك دعوات للطرفين وسمعنا
وهناك حث لهما من اجل تهدئه الاوضاع من
اجل القيام باي عمليه مماثله قريبا اذا
دعت الحاجه دائما كما يؤكد الامريكيون
هذا يعني انه ممكن يعني اذا رات الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه انه في حاجه ماسه لنقل
العاملين بالسفاره واجلاءهم قد تجبر
الاطراف على هدنه ربما لتامين عمليه النقل
هذه صحيح
على الامريكيون بغض النظر عن وجود
امريكيين هناك رعايه امريكيين وحتى موظفي
السفرهم يحثون الطرفين على الهدنه وعلى
الالتزام بوقف اطلاق النار ولكن موضوع
الرعايه الامريكيين وموضوع السفاره
الامريكيه والعاملين فيها كان له اولويه
منذ اليوم الاول منتهى عندما تحدث وزير
الخارجيه عن هذا الامر وقال بان الحكومه
الامريكيه ملزمه بحمايه امن هؤلاء
الموظفين وهي على تواصل الدائم معهم وحتى
في البيانات الاخيره قالوا بانهم على
التواصل مع الموظفين في السفاره مع الاسهل
الدبلوماسيه الامريكي وحملوا ايضا القضاء
العسكريين في السودان مسؤوليه حمايه
المواطنين المدنيين والمواطنين المدنيين
من دول اخرى بما في ذلك اعضاء السلك
الدبلوماسي وتحديدا اعضاء السلك
الدبلوماسي الامريكي لذلك نحن نلاحظ بان
هناك ضغوط تمارس من
الامريكيين على اطراف النزاع في السودان
من اجل حمايه هذا السلك الدبلوماسي ومن
اجل التوصل الى حل ربما من اجل العمليه
اخلاء اذا تمت اوضاعت الحاجه الى ذلك واضح
انه هذه المناشدات حتى الان لم تجد اذان
صاغيه لانه احنا بنحكي معك حسين ما زالت
هناك اصوات القذائف اصوات الاشتباكات
نسمعها وصحيح انه الشاشه بدون اناره شاشه
سوداء تاتينا من الخرطوم ولكن قد نرى
في في لحظات اواميد النيران والاشتباكات
بينهم كان الحديث ايضا حسين من بعض
المسؤولين في الاداره الامريكيه عن او من
مسؤولين في الاداره الامريكيه عن مره اخرى
عن عقوبات
تطال الاطراف في السودان لوقف هذه المعركه
اي نوع من العقوبات هنا نتحدث عندك فكره
بالفعل منتهى وهذا ما اعاد الحديث عنه
اعضاء في مجلس الشيوخ ومجلس النواب من انه
هناك
اذا نتذكر في ديسمبر عام 2022 بعد
سيطره المجلس العسكري على ازاحه المجلس
العسكري لحكومه
حمدوك من السلطه كان هناك تصويت في لجنه
العلاقات الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ على فرض
عقوبات على من يعيق
الانتقال المدني والسلمي في السودان
هذا هذا التصويت تمت هناك اعاده الحديث
عنه الان في اروقه الكونغرس الامريكي هناك
دعوات في في الكونجرس لاعاده فرض هذه
العقوبات او تفعيل هذه العقوبات على من
يعيق الانتقال السلمي هم بالنسبه لهم ما
جرى في في اكتوبر عام
2021 كان انقلابا عسكريا حسب وسط
الامريكيين لذلك هذا الحديث يتزايد الان
مع الاوضاع التي المتدهوره في السودان هي
عقوبات تشمل
اشخاص ستفرض على اشخاص
يصفونهم بانهم يعرقلون
انتقال السلمي في السودان من الحكومه
مدنيه ما يركز عليها المشرعون الامريكيون
يمكننا نتحدث عن مجلس النواب او مجلس
الشيوخ هو ان تكون هناك حكومه بقياده
مدنيه الامريكيون يريدون حكومه بقياده
مدنيه وليست بقياده عسكريه ويدعون
العسكريين للتنازل عن السلطه اولا
وللتحاور مع القيادات المدنيه من اجل
الوصول الى هذا الهدف بالنسبه للامريكيين
الشعب السوداني يريد ديموقراطيه وهذا هدف
يتقاطع مع ما يطالب به الامريكيون كما
يقولون يقولون بان السودانيين يريدون ان
يعود العسكر الى سكناتهم هذا هو صلب
الموضوع وهذا جوهر التحركات التي سمعناها
في الكونجرس تحدث الى العديد من المشرعين
كانوا جميعهم يقولون بان هذا العنف لن
يؤدي الى شيء لا يوجد حل عسكري يجب على
القاده العسكريين ان يجلسوا على طاوله
المفاوضات وان يعملوا على تسليم الحكومه
مدنيه السلطات في البلاد في نهايه المطاف
لان الوضع لن يكون مقبولا وهناك من اشار
بان العقوبات مطروحه على الطاوله وهم
مستعدون للتعامل معها ولفرضها على هؤلاء
الذين يتهمونهم بانهم يعقلون الانتقال
السلمي بالنسبه لفقه العوده من مره اخرى
الى موضوع اللاجئين المسؤولين الذي تحدثنا
معهم كانوا دائما
العمليات الجاريه في الخرطوم هذه
الاستمرار هذه العمليات هو اكثر ما
يعرقلاء
على
اسناده سنبقى على اتصال معك في حال ورود
اي مواقف امريكيه نستمع الى اصوات
الاشتباكات
العنيفه التي تتجدد في محيط القياده
العامه
والصوره
الخاصه بالعربيه مثبته هناك كاميرات
العربيه مثبته هناك لكن واضح انه لا
كهرباء في المنطقه على الاطلاق وانما
نستمع فقط لصوت الاشتباكات واطلاق النار
مقداد حسن مره اخرى صوت قوي جدا الحقيقه
كانه اشتباكات تجددت بقوه مره اخرى من نفس
البقعه ومن نفس المكان حيث
العربيه
عوده الى مقداد كان ينقل لنا الصوره من
منطقه دمار منطقه سكنيه حدث فيها دمار
كبير انا معك مره اخرى مقداد
نعم
نعم كما ترين الان انا من داخل هذه الشقه
التي تدمرت اثر هذه
الاشتباكات العنيفه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع انا الان من داخل هذه
الشقه التي يمتلكها كما ذكرت الفا وانا
كنت خارجها عبد الله ثروت الذي فقد جميع
ما يملك كما ترون الان هذه هي كبقايا
الاشياء لاطفاله ولزوجته وكذلك زوجته التي
هي تحمل طفلها السادس الذي بلغ صعوبه
كبيره في انقاذها من هذا الموقف يقول ان
والده زوجته والده زوجته ترقد كانت ترقد
هنا في هذا المكان بالضبط هنا حيث كما
ترون
القذيفه دخلت من هذه المنطقه وسببت دمار
هائل جدا على اثره فقدت
زوجه عبد الله التي تحمل طفلها السادس كما
قلت فقدت روحها وقضت روحها من هنا في هذا
بعد صعوبه بالغه في انقاذها واستخراجها من
هذه المكان صارعت الموت لساعتين او اكثر
هذه والده زوجه صح
والده زوجته التحركات والمستشفيات والد
الزودته نعم والده زوجته التي هي حامل
تحمل طفلها في شهرها السادسه كما ترون هنا
امام الان
المطبخ كانوا يطبخون فيه فتره يجهزون
حاجياتهم برمضان وهذه بعض
الحاجيات التي كانوا يفطرون بها في رمضان
هي الاخرى كانت جاهزه واصابها الدمار كما
ترون الان تدمر بالكامل
كما ترون الان يمكن وضاح ان تريد الى هذه
ما تبقى من
الشقه في هذه المنطقه هنا من هذا من هذه
النافذه تماما كما ذكر عبد الله ان هذه
النافذه تماما كانت محاوله شاقه جدا
لانقاذ جميع افراد اسرته والدته والده
زوجته وزوجته وطفلته التي
شعرت به ستيريه كبيره كما يقول وخوف وهلع
هم استيقظوا على دمار وعلى نيران وعلى
كذلك اصوات عاليه جدا كما يقول عبد الله
من هذه البلكونه وان هذه النافذه تماما
تمت عمليه الانقاذ تمت عمليه الانقاذ
وبمساعده
الشباب من هذه المنطقه شباب الحي ومواطنين
هذه المنطقه كذلك في خارج هذه الشقه هذا
المجمع السكني مجمع الرواد الذي [__] كما
قلنا سبعه عشره
برجا سكنيا
كامل
تعرضت السيارات المتاخمه او الواقعه
في القلطه بالدمار الكامل كما ترون هذه
بعض اشياء
دمار في حاجيات المنزل من
حديث
تعود على البني ادمين
يعني
هذه ايوه هذه الكثير من الدمار المادي
ومهما كان الدمار المادي يعني ارحم من
الارواح البشريه وانا معك كالوضع صعب جدا
لكن في حاله عبد الله وغيره من تتدمر
المنازلهم بهذه الطريقه وين بيروحوا اين
يلجاون
هو الان يسكن مع جيرانه في نفسه المنطقه
هنا السودانيين بطبعهم
يتشاركون هذه
الالام يحاولون ان يصيدون بعضهم البعض لا
يعني يتكاثفون تماما ويعينون بعضهم البعض
وهذه من صفات السودانيين التي يشهدها
اليوميه وفي صفاتهم الجميله
صحيح مقداد هذا مثال على واحده من الشقق
التي تمت تدمرت
والحقيقه يعني
قلوبنا مع كل احد يعني فقد عزيز عليه او
فقد حتى املاكه فقد بيته وغيره في السودان
واحده فقط كم عدد الشقق التي تضررت في هذا
المجمع السكني
حتى الان ما وردنا ان هذه الشقات تدمرت
دمارا كاملا لكن هنالك
شقه في البرج المجاور لهذه لهذه لهذه
الشقى تدمر دمارا جزئيا من اجداد معينه في
المبدا لكن
كما اسلفت انها قذيفه جاءت اثراء
الاشتباكات غير
الاشتباكات بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني يعني الله سترهم ما هو تحدث
السيد عبد الله بانه كانوا نيام الساعه
8:30 صباحا
وقعت القذيفه بهذا الشكل
يعني انا اريد ان اقول الف الحمد لله على
سلامه عائله زوجته جنينها
وهمم
وربي يعوض عن هذه الخسائر الماديه في
نهايه الامر ولكن هذا المنظر هذا المشهد
مثير
للشفقه في وضع في هذه الاوضاع التي نعيشها
الان غدا عيد الفطر السعيد اذا كان عبد
الله معك فقط يحدثنا واذا تمكنت انك تحدث
معه ويحدثنا كيف يعني كيف نيتهم بانه كيف
سيقدون غد الغد ماذا يعني ماذا سيفعلون في
صباح الغد
نعم عبد الله لك ان تحكي
تعوضون هذه الخسائر وكيف ستقضون يوم الغد
وانتم تستشرفون العيد
ليس لدينا اي مكان
ولا
احمل
ما لن يكفيني
استاجر
لا املك شيء اين تسكن الان اين تقيم اسرتك
الان ماذا فعل انا مستضيف من قبل اختي
ومن قبل صديقي بالخارج خارج المجمع
داخل المجمع
شقه صغيره قدر الاسره
بس انا ما بين اختي وما بين صديقي بالخارج
والحان انا لا املك هذا اللبس الذي انا
على جسدي من صديقك
خرجت من هذه الشقه
بملابس النوم انا وزوجتي وبنتي
لا املك شيء حتى خزنتي هل بها مالي الذي
تم توفيره طيله فتره خدمه في العمل وهي 15
سنه عمل كلها تم حرقها
مالي
[موسيقى]
والد الزوجه
ملابس كل شيء كل شيء عملي في الله ثم الله
نعم هذا هذه هي الصوره تماما من داخل منزل
عبد الله ثروت الذي حكى لنا ما ترون من
دمار
معه
وانساني ونحن نتالم لكل هذه الخسارات وحتى
الخسارات في الارواح هي اصعب بكثير داخل
السودان في هذه الازمه معلش ممكن اطلب منك
مره اخرى ان تجعله يعيد علينا الطريقه
التي تم التي يعني تعرض فيها بيتهم
للقذيفه وكيف تصرفوا كعائله
هل لك عبد الله ان تحكي لنا كيف تعرض
البيت للقذيفه وكيف انقذتم حاولتم انقاذ
الاسره احكي لنا القصه بتفاصيلها الكامله
طيب كما اسلفت انا كنت اركض في هذا المكان
هذه الصاله الخارجيه
انا وزوجتي
تسع سنوات
والده زوجتي
تربط داخل الغرفه الخارجيه وليست الداخليه
تمام
فانا اتكلم براحتي
فكنت هنا في حدود الساعه ثمانيه صباحا
8:30 في هذا المكان في هذا المكان في
الارض نعم ولولا
نومي في الارض
كنت الان اتحدث معك
هذه رحمه للربة انا هنا وزوجتي وبنتي كلهم
في احضاني
ثم يعني
مهما اوصف لك من من مشاعرك كيف كانت لحظات
الاولى الاستيقاظكم ما هي المشاعر ما هي
لا توجد مشاعر يوجد لهب
فقدنا الاتصال مع مقداد حسن في هذه
اللحظات كان يتحدث
مع احد المواطنين المدنيين السودانيين سيد
عبد الله الذي تعرض بيته
لقذيفه من هذه الاشتباكات وهذا النزاع
الدائر الان في السودان في منطقه جنوب
الخرطوم مجمع سكني جنوب الخرطوم يضم عدد
كبير من الشقق السكنيه المدنيه فقد فيها
الوالده زوجته واستطاع ان يقوم بانقاذ
زوجته الحامل بشهرها السادس واخراجها من
النافذه داخل المنزل وكانت هذا يعني كان
هذا كله مثال على حجم الدمار الذي يحدث
بسبب هذه
الحرب الدائره الان في السودان وطبعا ما
زلنا نتابع واياكم هذه الصور انقطاع
الكهرباء في الكرتون
العمليات الاشتباكات ما زالت قائمه
ومستمره في محيط القياده العامه للقوات
المسلحه
وقبل قليل مبادره القوى السودانيه تقول
حصلنا على موافقه مبدئيه من طرفي الصراع
لوقف النار خلال العيد اذا يبدو انه يبدو
انه هذه مبادره جديده من القوى السودانيه
تقول حصلنا على موافقه مبدئيه من طرفي
الصراع لوقف النار خلال العيد ووقت النار
بشكل كامل ربما من اجل الدخول في حوار بين
الطرفين لكن نقول ان المبادره
الموافقه ما زالت مبدئيه حتى الان ومبادره
القوى الوطنيه السودانيه تقول سنقدم
مبادره شامله لوقف النار والحوار لحل
الخلافات نتمنى ان يحدث ذلك القوى
السودانيه القوى الوطنيه السودانيه هي
القوه المدنيه
اصلا لم تتم استشارتها في موضوع هذه
المعركه القائمه بين الطرفين بين القوات
المسلحه
السودانيه
وقوات
الدعم السريع التي بقياده حمدتي محمد
حمدان دقلو قد تنجح هذه المبادره للقوى
الوطنيه السودانيه
وربما تكون القوى السودانيه المدنيه لها
داله على طرفي النزاع الان وما زلنا نستمع
الى صوت القذائف هو انقطاع الكهرباء في
هذه المنطقه القريبه من او في محيط
القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه السودانيه
الاشتباكات حولها بشكل كبير من اجل ربما
يعني محاوله اثبات السيطره من يستطيع ان
يسيطر على هذه المنطقه في نهايه الامر
يستطيع ان يثبت نفسه على الارض مبادره
القوى الوطنيه السودانيه اذا تقول نتيجه
المساعي للمبادرتنا ستكون خلال الساع
القادمه وعدوا بشكل مبدئي بان يتم وقف
الاطلاق النار ووقف القصف في خلال ايام
العيد وربما سيكون هذا سيهيا هذا لجلوس
الاطراف على طاوله الحوار لحل هذه الازمه
سلميا مع انه
لا يبدو في المواقف المعلنه حتى الان على
الاقل من تصريحات الصحفيه للطرفين سواء
الفريق حميتي او الفريق البرهان بانه في
امكانيه للجلوس على طاوله مفاوضات الا
بشروط كل منهما لكن من يدري ربما يكون
هناك قدره للقوى الوطنيه السودانيه
السياسيه حتى نصل الى حل هذه الازمه التي
تصاعدت منذ خمسه ايام حتى الان ويكاد
ينتهي اليوم السادس للمعارك في السودان
وحتى الان لم يظهر قائد قوات الدعم السريع
محمد حمدان حمدتي بشكل علني كما ان عبد
الفتاح البرهان قائد الجيش
ظهر لمره واحده في مقطع قصير من احد غرف
العمليه لنتابع
على مدار ايام سيطر اسمان على المسامع عبد
الفتاح البرهان قائد الجيش السوداني ومحمد
حمدان دقلو قائد قوات الدعم السريع القوات
التي تخضع لكل منهما تاخذ معارك محتدمه في
شوارع الخرطوم احتراب اندلعت شرارته
الاولى يوم الخامس عشر من ابريل ولا تزال
راحه دائره
تساؤلات تتنامى مع تطور المواجهه لعل
ابرزها لماذا يتجنب الخصمان الذهور لا احد
يمكن ان يجزم بمقر اقامه الخصمين خاصه ان
كل طرف يصر على الحسم فهي معركه وجوديه او
صفريه بقاء احد الطرفين يعني ان الاخر خرج
من المعادله السودانيه
عصر اليوم الاول من المعارك
ظهر البرهان في الخرطوم لخمسه عشره ثانيه
في مقطع مصور يرجح ان يكون التقط داخل
احدى غرف العمليات العسكريه من مقر
القياده العامه وبجواره قائد الحرس
الرئاسي ومجموعه من العسكريين يتابعون
الاحداث المشتعله ثلاثه اماكن قد يوجد
فيها البرهان داخل الخرطوم اما في قصر
الضيافه او القصر الجمهوري او القياده
العامه للجيش وهي الاماكن التي حاولت قوات
الدعم السريع السيط عليها وفي السابع عشر
من ابريل قصفت قوات الجيش احد المقرات في
حي المطار حيث رجحت القوات المسلحه وجود
قائد الدعم السريع محمد حمدان حمدتي
تقارير اخرى تشير الى ان دارفور قد تكون
ملاذا امنا في حال استمرت المعارك حيث
يتمتع هناك بنفوذ وسيطره ربما لا يتوفران
لديه في الخرطوم يكتفي كل من البرهان
وحميتي بالحديث الى وسائل الاعلام هاتفيا
وعلى مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ينقل
البرهان تصريحاته نصا عبر الصفحات الرسميه
للجيش السوداني بينما يلجا الى النصر عبر
حساباته على تويتر وفيسبوك
[موسيقى]
الامم المتحده للامن الغذائي في الشرق
الاوسط سابقا ينضم الينا عبر سكايب اهلا
بك معنا دكتور فاضل الزعبي واود ان نتحدث
عن مساله الامن الغذائي الان في السودان
اصلا كان هناك ازمه في السودان
وقضيه صعبه في في عمليه
التامين الحاجات اليوميه للمواطنين
السودانيين مع هذه المعركه مع هذه الحرب
ما الذي يمكن ان نتوقعه كيف ستعملون
مساء الخير وكل عام وانت بخير عيد سعيد ان
شاء الله على الجميع زي ما تفضلتي نعم
الوضع في السودان سابقا وقبل هذه المعارك
واحتدامها كان من ناحيه الامن الغذائي وضع
صعب جدا نتحدث عن بلد اكثر من 17% منها
يعانون انعدام الامن الغذائي اكثر من سبعه
مليون تقريبا
نتحدث عن عن بلد 92% من السكان لا
يستطيعون الوصول الى غذاء صحي وسليم هذا
جعل الوضع
الوضع الامني الغذائي يتفاقم مع وجود هذا
الصراع هذا الصراع ببساطه سوف يجعل كل
اليات الحكومه واليات المجتمع الدولي غير
قادره على
صيانه خطوط الامداد وسلسله الامداد سوف
يكون هنالك تقطع في سلسله الامداد سواء
بالغذاء او حتى بمياه الشرب وكذلك الرعايه
الصحيه الخدمات الاساسيه بشكل عام طبعا
سوف
[موسيقى]
دكتور فاضل الزعبي شكرا جزيلا لك على
المشاركه معنا الف شكر
[موسيقى]
وبعيدا عن اخبار السودان هذا موجز باهم
الانباء التي حدثت اليوم اعلنت المحكمه
العليا في السعوديه عن ان عيد الفطر هو
يوم الجمعه وذلك بعد ان تمت رؤيه الهلال
في مرصديت مير وحوطه سدير وذلك وفق ما
نقلت ديوان الملكي السعودي كما اعلنت
الامارات وقطر وعادت من الدول العربيه
والاسلاميه عن ان غدا الجمعه هو غره شهر
شوال اول ايام عيد الفطر
كل عام وانتم بخير ادرجت الحكومه
السويسريه مجموعه فاجنر العسكريه الخاصه
ووكاله الانباء الفيدراليه الروسيه رمضان
على قائمه العقوبات ضد روسيا وجاء في بيان
نشر على موقع الحكومه السويسريه ان اداره
الشؤون الاقتصاديه والتعليم والابحاث
المسؤوله عن العقوبات وسعت قائمه العقوبات
ضد روسيا وان العقوبات ستدخل حيز التنفيذ
اليوم الخميس بدءا من الساعه السابعه
بالتوقيت المحلي لموسكو
اكد الامين العام لحلف شمال الاطلسي ينسى
اثناء زياره الى كيف ان اولويه الحلف
تتمثل بضمان تغلب اوكرانيا في الحرب على
روسيا وقال بان مستقبل اوكرانيا هو داخل
العائله الاوروبيه الاطلسيه وسيتم بحث خطه
انضمامها للنيتو خلال القمه التي ستعقد في
شهر يوليو
وقال رئيس الاوكراني
ان الوقت حان لدعوه كييف للانضمام الى حلف
شمال الاطلسي واتخاذ القرار المناسب جاء
هذا في اطار اول زياره يقوم بها الامين
العام لحلف الناتو الى كيف والتي تندرج
ضمن مساعيه لمواصله دعم اوكرانيا
قالت وزاره دفاع الروسيه بان قواتها نفذت
10 طلعات جويه لدعم وحدات الهجوم في ارتيو
موسكو وتمكنت من تدمير مقر قياديه
اوكرانيه على الجبهه واشارت الى ان مدفعيه
مجموعه القوات الجنوبيه نفذت 64 مهمه قصف
ومنعت القوات الاوكرانيه من القيام بهجوم
مضاد
اعلن ديميتري بسكوف المتحدث باسم الكرملين
ان ترى سانتين النوويتين لفرنسا وبريطانيا
هما تحت سيطره الولايات المتحده ويجب
تخفيضهما وقال بسكوب انهم اذا تحدثوا
للولايات المتحده دون مراعاه هات هاتين
الترسنتين فلا معنى لاي محادثات خاصه ان
فرنسا وبريطانيا نظام متكامل لحلف النيتو
الخاضع لسيطره الولايات المتحده
ابدت الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه التي تسيطر
على مناطق واسعه شمال وشمال شرق سوريا
ابدت موافقه مشروطه على لقاء الحكومه
السوريه للتواصل الى حل للازمه بينهما
واكدت الاداره في بيان استعدادها للحوار
مع الحكومه السوريه ومع جميع الاطراف
السوريه وبحث المبادرات تؤدي الى مخرج
للازمه السوريه وضع البيان الدول العربيه
والامم المتحده والقوى الدوليه الفاعله في
الشان السوري لتاديه دور ايجابي يسهم في
الوصول الى حل وفق البيان
وعلى اثر رفع سن التقاعد القانوني في
فرنسا الى سن 64 عاما تظاهر اكثر من مئه
من عمال السكك الحديديه في محطه بمدينه
ليون وطلبوا المتظاهرين بضروره ستار قرار
يتضمن اصلاح المعاشات التقاعديه فضلا عن
مطالبات طالت الرئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل
ماكرون بضروره نحيه عن منصبه الرئاسي في
البلاد
شهدت الثلاث ثلاثه مطارات في المانيا حاله
من الاضطرابات من عناصر قوى الامن في مطار
هامبورغو وجلدورف وكولونيا وذكر بيان صادر
عن الجمعيه الالمانيه للموانئ الجويه ان
الاضراب
سينتج عنه الغاء حوالي 700 رحله جويه في
المطارات الثلاث خلال يومي الخميس والجمعه
مضيفه الى ان حوالي اكثر من 45 الف مسافر
اضطروا الى تغيير خطط سفرهم
[موسيقى]
ونعود لاخبار السودان ساره عثمان فتاه في
الثانيه والعشرين من عمرها ضحيه جديده في
اشتباكات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع في حي
الفتحابا بمدينه ام درمان اصابتها رصاصه
طائشه في محيط سكنها استقرت الرصاصه في
قلبها فيما كانت تجلب الماء المنعدم منذ
ايام لاسرتها كاميرا العربيه زارت الاسره
المفجوعه ونقلت معاناتها
[موسيقى]
اجان الولد جاري قال يا اخي انضربت ما
معروف انضربت
حتى عرفنا انها مضروبه في جهه
نزيف ثقيل جدا يعني نظافه نزيف ثقيل جدا
وللاسف الشديد مع اننا اي طوارئ
ومشاهدينا الكرام بهذا انتهت هذه الساعه
التي خصصنا جلها لتغطيه ما يحدث في
الخرطوم في السودان وننتقل واياكم الى
راويه للمزيد من الاخبار ربما سيتم
الاتفاق على غدنا اليك راويه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات